Deputy leader of the opposition Angela
Reyna
hey Mr Speaker speaking of the last
election the Tory Manifesto promised to
end the abuse of the judicial review
how's it going
well I I welcome the much shorter
question from the writer of a lady today
let me just remind the right honoral
lady I have a few facts about the covert
inquiry we set up the covert inquiry we
have provided it with more than 55
000 documents so far we have given it
all the financial resources it needs so
that we can learn the lessons from the
pandemic but Mr Speaker in Wales they
also had a pandemic and what have the
labor run Wales authorities done there
no independent inquiry in Wales
as ever one rule for labor and another
for everyone else
speaking he acts like it's pretends that
it's complicated but it's simple they
felt the inquiry to get to the truth
then block that inquiry from getting the
information that it need us for and now
they're taking it to court I know he
considers himself among other people so
using his vast knowledge of working
class Britain does he think working
people will thank him for spending
hundreds of thousands of pounds of their
money on loophole lawyers just so that
their government can obstruct the covert
inquiry
the Prime Minister well we will provide
the inquiry with each and every document
related to covid including all internal
discussions in any form as requested
while crucially protecting what is Holy
and unambiguously irrelevant because
essentially the right honorable lady is
calling for years worth of documents and
messages between named individuals to be
in scope and that Mr Speaker could cover
anything from civil servants medical
conditions to intimate details about
their families but I really will say to
the right honorable lady I find it
extraordinary that she should lecture us
on value for money for the taxpayer when
I understand she has now purchased two
pairs of noise canceling headphones on
expenses
no I will be fair I will be fair to the
right honorable lady if I had to attend
Shadow cabinet meetings I think I'd want
to tune them out too
can I just say that Deputy Prime
Minister was very good saying he was
welcoming short questions I'd also
welcome shorter answers
far and across the world covered
inquiries are well underway while his
government hides into infant and shells
out public money on legal bills for the
Oxbridge one the
minister is now demanding another
million to pay for his new lawyers now I
know the honorable gentleman and his
former boss has fallen out and maybe he
wants to patch things up but can he
seriously say this is a good use of
taxpayers money
that's the Prime Minister if we want to
talk about relationships between between
different people I don't think we need
to search her WhatsApp messages to know
that there's no communication between
her and the leader of her party
and I will happily happily stand up for
our record on covid because when she and
her party were carping from the
sidelines calling for longer lockdowns I
was working as culture secretary to keep
our football clubs running to protect
our theaters and museums and deliver the
largest cultural recovery package in the
western world
that's the difference between her and me
Mr Speaker while she was collecting
titles I was getting on with a job
because I know for the last couple of
years he's been trying to prep p.m Prime
Ministers for this but these punch lines
of dire he really needs to go back to
school himself
thousands of children are missing from
school absence has nearly doubled since
before the pandemic the Prime Minister
says he's maxed out on his support for
school pupils but why did the government
abandon its plans for a register of
missing children
the Prime Minister
well on the specifics of the writing or
ladies question that is not the case and
we continue to keep the policy under
review and what I would say is I am
I'm
I am very proud of this government's
record on funding and support for
schools four billion pounds more this
year four billion pounds next year and
the result of all of that investment is
we have the highest standards of reading
in the entire Western World what a
contrast from when the party offers it
we're in power
Angela Reyna so there we have it Mr
Speaker thousands of children listen
under review still so let me ask him
about another uh something else that's
gone missing the Public Accounts
committee this week revealed that the
government's fraud increased fourfold
with ministers overseeing the loss of 21
billion pounds of taxpayers money in the
last two years can he tell us how much
of our money they expect to recover
that the prime minister
Mr Speaker we are working tirelessly to
recover those funds and have made and we
have made huge progress already but
again if the party opposite
wants to talk about wants to talk about
good use of taxpayers money what do we
have from the party opposite
plans for an unfunded 28 billion pounds
spending spree and what would that do
drive up borrowing push up interest
rates adding a thousand pounds to
everyone's mortgage Mr Speaker I know
they're out of touch but even she must
realize that Britain cannot afford labor
enough
cabrin can't afford any more of the
[Applause]
the answer is a quarter only a quarter
of the billions of pounds of taxpayers
money lost to fraud is expected to be
clawed back if this government can't get
the public money back they can't be
trusted with anything else if become a
pattern of behavior from the
conservatives and an inquiry missing the
evidence schools missing their pupils
taxpayers missing their money and
ministers missing in action and all the
while working people pay the price for
their mistakes this week the Public
Accounts committee also warned that this
epic fraud and waste could happen all
over again due to the ministers living
in denial of the facts if it's
government can't admit the truth then
how on Earth can they learn the lessons
[Music]
I'm the prime minister
well I would say to the random lady
we're actually putting more resources in
throughout this year to tackle fraud and
error and we continue to make real
progress with it but again it's quite
extraordinary from the from the from the
party opposite well we are working to
drive down inflation and energy bills
what's what's the writer of a lady doing
receiving 10 000 pounds from just stop
oil backers
adopting their policies backing
protesters blocking new production and
forcing us to import more foreign oil
and gas do you know what for once Mr
Speaker I find myself in agreement with
the GMB Union what did they say
it's naive lacks intellectual rigor and
could decimate communities just like
labor
[Applause]